[Music]
Hey everyone, I'm Nikil. I'm the
co-founder CEO of Cloud Chef. Today I'm
going to tell you guys how we took a
general purpose robot that was not meant
for cooking. It was just a robot with
two hands. how we trained it or put it
through culinary school and it's now a
professional chef that's working in
various different kitchens doing actual
real work like a chef. So before we get
into that a quick thing about cloud chef
our mission basically is to make
highquality nutritious food affordable
to everyone and the only way we know how
to do it at this point is by automating
all commercial labor or all commercial
kitchen labor with what we call culinary
intelligent robots. So, robots that can
act, sense, and reason and behave in the
real world like a chef. So, you guys
probably all have seen the Tesla Optimus
dancing, and like I've seen it, too. And
the immediate question that comes to
mind is maybe this is how a robot chef
will be where, you know, it's it's it's
in the kitchen, it's beating down
equipment, whatnot, right?
But turns out that those guys are a
little too expensive. They're not really
there yet. There are lots of problems
with humanoids. But on the other hand,
if you look at form factors like these,
they're also general purpose. They're
basically just two hands in a mobile
base that can move around and actually
do all the work that a regular
chef would be able to do. And as
compared to humanoids, these are now way
cheaper than human labor. Like
humanoids, if you plot them on this
curve, you'll probably not even see them
at this point because of like how
unreliable they are, how much
maintenance it requires. But these
wheeled robots with two hands, no
problem. Way cheaper than a human uh way
cheaper than any human uh chef. But
what's missing is actually,
you know, software. And what we did was
we took that, we took this robot, like I
said, we put it through culinary school
and now we have chef-like robot labor.
So you uh commercial facilities can hire
this robot, pay it hourly wages like $12
an hour. It'll always show up. No
overtime, no turnover, no uh calling in
sick and just or even better than a
human, it plugs in place into any
arbitrary novel kitchen. So it learns
new recipes from one expert
demonstration and it is robust to
ingredient variation, appliance
variation, and can cook on arbitrary
portion sizes. This is actually a task
that's actually harder for humans to do
too. Like when I say we put these robots
through culinary school, what we
actually do is like what is culinary
school for a robot? It needs to learn
all the motion primitives that come with
human beings. So how do you pick
something? How do you stir a pot? And to
do that we have these robot foundation
models that we fine-tune. We have teley
operation to fall back for all these
edge cases.
But that's not enough. Like you still
need the robot to understand food. Like
are the onions brown enough? Are are the
onions brown enough? If you're cooking
steak, is it like shrinking well enough?
If you're cooking shrimp, uh do you can
you sense when the shrimp is done? And
these are like ingredients that vary
seasonally, daily, like onions today
might require 7 minutes to saute. It'll
require like 9 minutes to saute
tomorrow. And we basically
uh have thermal and visual embeddings
that are specific to cooking that help
us reason through these like unseen
environments. And we've basically
modeled recipes as state machines based
on these embedding models at the core.
And now even if even after you have
this, the next thing that you need is it
needs to adapt to any new kitchen that
it has never seen before. So it needs to
be able to see a recipe once, understand
what to do and interact with real humans
in a workflow and actually do work. So
we put our culinary understanding to the
test and we at this point do better than
even expert chefs in their cuisine of
training. And like if you take so
basically we evalu
across a mix of cuisines. We got uh
given the task was given live cooking
data, an expert demonstration and a text
recipe, can you estimate where in the
cooking process you are? Can you track
progress uh like a human being? We put
it through this expert human chefs who
get paid more than $150,000 a year still
perform worse than our tiny model that's
doing perception in this case. And in
fact, when we put like state-of-the-art
models like Gemini 2.5 or 03, they
actually perform way worse than our own
models and that's partly because they
don't have any thermal modality. And the
thing is thermal modality does not have
internet scale data. So what we did is
we went and installed sensors in active
commercial kitchens, collected hundreds
of thousands of uh collected data worth
hundreds of thousands of live cooked
meals in various kitchen environments
across various different recipes,
cuisines and seasons. So we collected
this private data, we trained a model,
we scraped a bunch of public data like
uh trained some self-supervised models
on that and a combination of this is
basically what our culinary system uh
banks on. And it is what I like I said
is now way better than human chefs at
just decision-m during cooking. But
motor skills on the other hand, it's not
as good as a human, but it is getting
there. So we again put it through all
these different evals. was sautéing,
it's almost as fast as the human cook,
picking and pouring, slightly less fast,
grilling, stirring. So, it's all a bunch
of evals that we did on top of motor
skills. And this is how in fact our
system is right now about 95%
autonomous, 5% teleyoperated. And it's
way faster and way more reliable than
just teleyop or just foundation models.
And basically the robot comes into a
kitchen like I said looks at a recipe
once from a chef and it's just able to
do it. So for example here it's cooking
a recipe from a two Michelin star chef
who's based out of San Francisco and
basically while it's cooking it's
looking at how the onions are browning.
It's comparing it to how brown the
onions were getting when the chef was
cooking it. Takes it to the right amount
of brownness. It knows exactly what to
do for the next recipe where the
ingredients are kept. It's not
pre-programmed to know where the
ingredients are, what kind of uh what
kind of variation you'll find. It is
doing all that reasoning within the
system itself. So
yeah, so if we
go further and there's a recipe, we'll
see how uh it's cooking this chicken.
It's basically getting clean readings
every single uh every few minutes. And
at the end of it, I will basically show
you what happens. And yeah, at the end
of it, you have actual. So these are
actually recipes that go into the the
stomachs of actual real customers. So
the robots cooking at various different
facilities at this point. It's sorry,
it's deployed in the real world and
yeah, so it's deploy it's deployed in
the real world. It's being used in all
all these sorts of kitchens. On the
right, you can see it cook recipes in
our in-house kitchen. On the left, it's
also like CCTV footage of the robot
doing some operation. Uh I'm I'm not
even sure. I just pulled it off of our
of the CCTV before getting on stage and
just pulled it up here. And this is
video from a couple of months ago where
the robot's doing uh regular cooking
like a human being. And outside of uh
our own facilities, this is how for
example the robots working at one of our
customers facilities doing chicken
wings. It's basically fetching the
chicken wings from some place uh kept to
the side, waits for the uh cook to be
done. Uh now it'll basically collect the
cooked chicken, put put it inside a bowl
and goes ahead, sauces it and mixes it
like a human being. And while doing this
the robot has a robot is practically a
weighing scale itself. So it knows
exactly what amount of ingredients it
has put in. It knows how much it has
stirred and yeah so basically we are
cloud chef like I said. Uh at this point
we're hiring uh we are a very small
team. We are growing super fast and
we're looking for people in software, ML
and robotics. If you know anyone please
uh reach out to me. My email address is
nicilcloudshef.co.
And yeah thank you. If any of you have
any questions, I'm happy to take it.
Thank you.
So for us, success means two things. One
is how good is the robot at
understanding what's happening in the
cooking process. So uh very simple
intuition for that is okay if you give
the entire cooking feed to a human being
and if you give the entire cooking like
video video and uh infrared feed to our
system which estimates state better
because once you have a cooked recipe
you can use that as label data to
understand okay if uh the system
predicts that this is 40% done was it
actually 40% done or was it actually 50%
done that's actually a supervised
learning signal that we can get after We
uh uh uh have data from like recreations
like any food recreation from any chef
with thermal and uh RGB footage. We're
able to do that. The other part is like
motions like how fast is the robot able
to do physical motions as compared to a
human being which I said we're not as
good as human beings yet. It's it's
basically a data problem. The more data
we get, the better we the better and
faster we get at doing any individual uh
task inside. Does that answer your
question?
Yes. For the end taste. So the thing
that we realized is as a professional
like no professional chef is cooking to
chemical cons like to consistency that's
that can be measured in any chemical
way. So our competition is not getting
chemical level consistency every single
time. It's about it's about getting
consistency to a degree that is better
than a chef can do a second time. So a
common benchmark that we do is we get a
chef to cook a recipe once and then we
get our system when I we get our robot
recreate that recipe a couple of times
and then we do blind taste tests and so
those are more unscalable emails that we
do inhouse which act as a higher signal
to okay actually the end product that we
get is better than what uh chefs are
able to do.
No, it's basically just hand uh two
hands on a mobile base uh with some
cameras and stuff on it. It shows up at
the kitchen. You basically interact with
it like a human being and that's the
form factor there. There's no uh
additional screens etc. Those are just
for video sake.
Uh it depends. Uh ideally humans don't
need to but today in some deployments
humans do end up doing it but our idea
is that because the robot h we because
we have joint torque data from like all
the different motors from the robot the
robot itself is a weighing scale. So
when it picks up something it already
knows how heavy it is.
So that is one thing that we've worked a
lot worked on a lot where we are able to
work on arbitrary unseen appliances
because our sensing stack is so good and
uh the other thing is almost all
appliances inside kitchens are
controlled using knobs. So the motion
primitive that the robot needs is to
know how to turn a knob and then uh our
control systems take care from there.
Yeah. Sure.
Does this have where it can move
automatically?
Yes.
Yeah.
mostly because
you guys can go right now.
So, uh, right now for most motions, we
are anywhere between like 80 to 95% the
speed of a human being. And ideally,
there's nothing stopping robots from
being even faster than human beings.
It's mostly just a data problem. Right
now the reason why it's not as fast as
human beings is because the data that we
collect on these robots are done by
human beings who telly operate the robot
and because human beings telly operating
the robot are not as intuitive at telly
operating the robot as their own bodies
they're not as fast as so the data is
kind of slow and then over time we
expect with RL and stuff it'll be faster
to this
yeah So uh there's nothing stopping a
robot from doing that either. It's just
we don't have like we haven't gone out
collected data for those tasks yet. So
it's just something on our road map. We
are very much blind to that.
Where can we eat this?
Oh, you can eat this in Palo Alto. So if
you're in San Francisco, if you order
from Wingstar, that's a customer of ours
who uses it. So you'll get it from
there. If you're in Palo Alto, you can
order from India's top 20 and it'll you
can eat from there as well. Or if you're
in Menlo Park, you can go to this uh
high-end Indian restaurant called Alan
and you some of the food there is also
cooked by it.
We've uh we've asked questions around
like chopping and food preparation and
whatnot and like a speed of the robot
but in terms of uh throughput in the
actual process uh how much of that even
matters like uh you know how much of the
energy already goes in you know
throughout the day into prep versus the
like uh 90 you know percent or 80% like
does that matter this is not a
manufacturing facility. uh when it comes
to servicing like how much of the
economic value is already taken care of
because you have the telly operator in
the back to make sure things are insured
have you guys found that meaningful or
is that not a big deal at all and not a
like is that trivial essentially at this
point
great question so basically what uh the
quick answer to that is about 50% of the
labor cost inside any kitchen is line
cooking labor and that's where we are
going at first and the
advantage there I mean uh speed does
play a factor But there's another uh
variable that we have in our control
which is we are able to speed up recipes
uh more than any human being is able to
do because we know exactly like we've
had several instances where we've
recorded like we've observed a chef in
motion and realized that oh this process
that takes them 20 minutes to do can
actually be done in 14 minutes. So if
the robot is even like 10% slower it
doesn't really matter. That's how it
works.
Then a tiny follow up to that is like
I guess it works
more than 40 hours a week. Does this
like process?
Yeah. Unlike a human being who uh after
working 40 hours a week uh goes into
overtime territory, robot can work for
like 168 hours. Like there's nothing
stopping a robot from working for 24/7.
The practical constraint is most
facilities don't operate 24 hours. So
the robot will operate as long as the
facility is operating and then there are
some tasks that you can do overnight. So
once we get into cutting, chopping etc.
The robot will just be doing that
overnight before the actual stuff comes
in.
Sorry, mine was kind of related to
before. So did this did you find new
bottlenecks and things like dishwashing,
crosscontamination, stuff that you maybe
weren't expecting to deal with this
process? So
dishwashing etc. Not that much. And even
for things like crosscontamination, we
just put small gloves on the robot and
then like our customers switch that out
every day. They were these are washable
small silicone pads. I can pull up the
video on that. But basically that's how
we take care of it. And then uh for
things like dishwashing, those are not
tasks that we are envisioning doing in
the short term. we want to do more of
the tasks that actually add to the
quality of the food that's being uh put
out. So that's why we are mostly focused
on line cooking for now. Maybe sometime
later like prepping, chopping, etc.
Last question.
Oh yeah. Uh sorry. Um so there was uh it
learns from chefs, right? The recipes
from chefs. Is it able to modify steps
of a recipe to cook things faster?
So that is still an experimental phase.
There are cuisines in which we are able
to do this really well but we aren't yet
able to do this across all cuisines. So
for cuisines where the thermodynamic
dynamics modeling of uh what's happening
in the process is straightforward it is
much more easier to uh basically like uh
fasten like speed recipes up uh do minor
variations etc. And there are some cases
where it's not that easy. It's a it it
is still like experimental territory.
We're still working on that.
Yeah. Last question.
Uh in the current version, it alerts
somebody in the facility that the robot
needs ingredients to work and then they
they take care of it. Hopefully once
there are enough robots in the facility,
they'll just talk to each other. And uh
thank you so much
[Music]